would love this with your animals i
brought my dog bella to a new dog park
this morning and i thought they were
doing some special training on the side
so i didn't want to disturb you know but
then they're like come on over so yes
yes big group of dogs we're all hanging
out lovely people yeah great to see them
and the weather was great aside from the
smoke of course yeah but temperatures
are great in the morning if we just get
rid of this hazelnut
this is the big problem guys this
outside yeah and it's worse than when
you see it at night because it's
reflecting off of the lights right i
noticed it so unfortunately we have that
to deal with for the day today but there
is some improvement in the air quality
and i think you're going to like the
forecast
coming up live look outside there from
one of our tower campuses our molaskey
corporate cam looking towards the strip
still that haze blanket of haze over the
valley at this hour 86 degrees right now
yesterday the high was 94. probably not
going to reach 90 today good to see that
right 14 for our humidity your dew point
32 degrees so very dry outside currently
outside here your temps 89 in sky canyon
centennial hills same for you we're 86
alliante camino el norte north las vegas
double eights along with nellis along
with sunrise manor 87 whitney ranch
double eights also for henderson 84
mountains edge and rhodes ranch in
southern highlands you're currently at
85. outside of town here you go 78 for
sandy valley 88 boulder city prompt
jumped off the map there i apologize 93
for laughlin 94 currently for death
valley here's a look right at the
weather now radar so showers and storms
way up there into central
central lincoln county and moving its
way into utah this is ahead of that cold
front because that cold front creates
lift to create these thunderstorms that
front now is starting to pass through
the region there it is and this is
important because when that front comes
through it's kicking up the winds from
the southwest but when it comes through
we're going to see the winds that shift
from the north and what that's going to
do is push that smoke out of the region
it's also going to bring us breezy winds
that will usher in cooler air behind the
hence cold front
cooler temperatures behind this means
highs tomorrow will still stay in the
80s but most importantly we'll see those
temperatures in the morning drop to the
low 60s here's your smoke forecast with
the passage of that cold front a lot of
that smoke is going to be pushed down to
the south still some haze around but
it's not going to be as dense or as
concentrated as what we saw this morning
so that's good the air quality advisory
in play should be allowed to expire
we'll see if it gets reissued or
extended
for tomorrow if it does we'll be the
first to let you know 65 overnight skies
will be clearing breezy winds those
gusts up to 25 so don't expect any
strong damaging winds overnight 82 for
tomorrow cooler and not as hazy now this
is where we should be
and we'll be breezy at times
temperatures will be some eight degrees
below normal look at these numbers for
your highs tomorrow low 80s across the
valley meaning somebody the kirsten get
her some pom-poms get her kissed in some
pom-poms
former mercer island cheerleader there
79 for someone 79 also these are the big
numbers 79 look at this anthem 79
summerlin 81 north las vegas it's going
to feel real nice highs tomorrow outside
the valley 82 for prompt 79 boulder city
89 for a lot so still a little bit warm
for you for laughlin but an improvement
right so temperatures will be in the 80s
and then back to the 90s for the weekend
but take a look at the morning lows low
60s coming up i'm going to show you
neighbor by neighbor how chilly it's
going to get in your neighborhood in our
next weather update in the meantime guys
we'll send it back over to you woohoo i
am